former Pakistani prime minister Imran
Khan is set for another court appearance
this Tuesday he's facing legal
four cases including attempted murder
and one related to party funding he will
face the charges in Islamabad it's the
first time he'll be in the city since an
assassination attempt which took place
in November let's go to Kamal Haider who
is in Islamabad Kamal can you go through
all the charges that Imran Khan is
facing
well indeed the charges are basically
the foreign funding cases there are
allegations uh that Imran received
imran's party received from funds from
overseas and there are of course also
charges of murder which is of course a
serious charge and that was also
pertaining to
basically writing that took place so
political undress that took place in the
city there is also the charge of the
toshahana which is basically all the
gifts that are received by the heads of
state Imran of course is being accused
of taking some of those gifts at the
very small price and then selling them
off so Imran has got now over 32 cases
against them from terrorism to sedition
to money laundering and of course has
been facing the course uh earlier he
went to the Lahore High Court despite
the fact that his lawyers had said that
his wounds that he received earlier in
November from that assassination attempt
required him to take risk because this
is a critical healing moment but Imran
of course has been appearing and as you
can see behind me there is a huge
traffic jam because thousands of his
supporters have also come to Islamabad
are converging at the court which is
just a stone throw from where we are and
that is where he's going to be facing
the court yeah as you say Kamal his
supporters are very passionate about him
uh what's the mood there from them on
the streets of Islamabad today
well as I mentioned there is a very
large crowd of supporters party workers
who have converged because this is Imran
Khan's first visit to Islamabad or first
appearance after that assassination
attempt there has been a Groundswell of
support for the former prime minister
after he was ousted in a vote of no
confidence he dissolved the provincial
Assemblies of the Punjab and the
khyberbuktundqua province because that
almost amounts to 60 percent of the
electorate therefore that there should
be an election a re-election for those
provinces the court of course is also
now deciding on a very important case
because the government has been dragging
its feet on holding those elections for
the provincial assemblies and that of
course goes against Pakistani
Constitution which states that they have
to be held within 90 days
okay thank you for that Kamal heida
there for us live in Islamabad